[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So, it used to be
that a sign of prosperity
was being given more choices.
Freedom meant the
freedom to choose.
But what happens when we become
victims of our own success?
Nowadays, there's
so many signals
competing for our attention
that it's been said,
if you don't have ADD today,
you're not paying attention.
We're all kind of suffering
through this paralysis
of choice, this
bandwidth anxiety,
this fractured attention
span, because we
go to the supermarket, and there
is just too much to pick from.
There's too many options.
We lack the RAM to process
all these possibilities.
We experience, instead, the
angst of FOMO, the angst
that no matter what we
choose, we are missing out
on something else.
And so the exhilaration,
the prosperity
of choice, the prosperity of
freedom has become oppressive.
It's become the
paralysis of choice.
And so what, then, is
the future of design?
What kind of new software
platforms and new interfaces
between self and the
world and what we consume
are we going to create
that don't overwhelm us,
but that instead induce
flow, that reduce friction?
The best technology
reduces friction,
lets you achieve something,
and then gets out of the way.
So I read an article
recently in "Fast Company"
that said that the future of
design is anticipatory choice.
It's this notion that we're
going to offload decisions
to algorithms that
are going to know us
better than we know ourselves.
So that when we
walk upon the world,
options will be afforded to us
and offered to us only when it
intuitively makes sense.
We will never be
bombarded by too much.
Things will just open up
a garden of forking paths.
Everything will be engaging
and delivered to us at a dosage
that we can process.
It'll be like being in the
flow, where you're not really
lacking anything,
and the right thing
is served up to your frontal
lobe when useful and needed.
But it'll never be running
around a crowded city,
overwhelmed by FOMO
and dying from inside
because of the anxiety.
So, I actually think that this
is going to kind of awesome.
I mean, some people are scared
it's going to create idiocracy,
and we're all going to
be numbed into stupors.
But I don't think so.
I think we're all going to be
hand delivered universes that
extend our imaginations
to spaces and places
and virtualities we
cannot even imagine.
I think the games are
going to get better.
And I think we're going
to offload ourselves
into the games.
We're going to live inside
of our imaginations,
and things will be served up
to us as needed, when needed.
And it'll be amazing.
We're all going to be on
this amazing hero's journey,
and it's going to be great.
We won't be weighed down
by RAM or stupid decisions.
No stupid options
to choose from.
[MUSIC PLAYING]